people here in the opposition held
Northwest Syria have lived through 12
years of war
but many say last month's earthquakes
have left them facing their greatest
loss
Abu musfi's entire family was killed
I was at the bakery when the earthquakes
hit the area I immediately rushed to my
house I was shocked by the scene of my
destroyed house all my family died under
the rubble my six children and my wife
he wonders if he can ever recover
Batman I'm now staying in this tent with
my parents they're all that I have left
after I lost my family they were my only
hope in this life now I have lost
everything and I have no hope in the
future
officials estimate most of the more than
20 000 damage buildings are
uninhabitable
thousands of people are now living in
shelters
adding to those already forced from
their homes by the war
well
we are living in continuous fear and
suffering we can't go back to our houses
because they are severely damaged by the
earthquake
we've been living here for a month and
we don't know how long we will be forced
to stay here
many here say more lives could have been
saved if the International Community had
responded faster
foreign
civil defense teams have been responding
since the first hours of the disaster
we've faced many challenges and
difficulties such as a lack of enough
heavy extraction tools and vehicles and
now more than forty thousand families
were displaced by the catastrophe
we went through many emotional
situations and we still hear the voices
of the women and children who were
trapped under the rubble although a
month has passed since then
after facing Gears of War on neglect the
6th of February will always be
remembered by those who survived the
earthquakes they now face more trauma
and little hope of ever achieving a
normal life